today i'm going to be showing you an
update to the new clips app on the
iphone which is really exciting because
this app has been desperately needing an
update before you could only shoot
square videos but now it's been updated
so you can shoot vertical and horizontal
and
there is now support for hdr video on
the new iphone 12 and of course if you
do have the iphone 12
obviously the processor is much faster
so you will be able to do things much
quicker so i'm just going to get into
this because i really want to show this
to you i did a video on this when it
first came out but they have a bunch of
new features
some new filters they now have over 100
royalty-free tracks
so you can do all kinds of really fun
stuff but i want to show you
first what i'm most excited about the
fact that you can now
do vertical video hey guys i wanted to
show you some of the test videos and
photos that i shot on the brand new
iphone 12. i'm gonna trim this a little
i'm gonna add some effects they have all
kinds of fun little effects
this is the vivid cool one actually that
i use a lot when i'm taking photos
so i think i'm actually i'm going to use
that so here's some text that you can
add
i'll do so this happened
you can also change the text to be
whatever you want it to be
stay with iphone
12. i'm gonna add a little song
oh that's nice so you can also do live
titles which is kind of cool
now let's bring in some photos so here's
my little picture
so now that i want to bring this photo
in i'm just going to hit record and this
will also record the sound of your voice
but you can mute it later so you press
and hold
however long you want this photo to be
inserted into the timeline
so i'm going to do i don't know like
three seconds
i'm going to go in i'm going to mute
that audio so that you don't have me
talking
you also notice that that little text
that i added
right here that is pinned to the side of
my hair you can also turn that off
depending upon if you want that to be
pinned or not so
awesome it was so pretty at the beach i
mean original audio
and you now just have the soundtrack
what else do we have
this is like a pretty long clip but it's
cool you can just slide your finger
right across
and this will let you choose what piece
of content you want
the first version of this was very
simple and i feel like they took all of
the tools that they had before and just
elevated them they are way more advanced
but it's still very simple to use
but look how easy this is like i'm just
dropping photos in here this would have
honestly normally taken me
way too much time to do in final cut
when i just wanted to make something
super simple for social i'm just gonna
keep their best day ever sticker
so now that i've got some content in i
want to shoot another quick little video
here
and this time i'm going to use my memoji
thanks for watching my little mini video
here that i made on clips i hope you
enjoyed it i had so much fun making it
look for more soon bye
it can be any emoji drawing me the
giraffe maybe do i want to be a shark
maybe owl
sure so at the top you have three
options you can do 16 by nine four
three or square and once your
masterpiece is complete you can share
this out
when you click options this will give
you the option to export it as a video
or as a project clips now has updated
ipad support so you are able to edit in
a horizontal format so i'll show you
guys that in a second but right now i'm
just going to export this as
a video for the time being and then i'm
going to send this project to my ipad
so i can continue working on it there so
if i do decide that i want to switch
this to a 4 3 or a square ratio i can do
that before i export it i can also
change it to horizontal
but i am pretty happy with my vertical
video so i'm going to save this out make
sure you guys follow me on twitter and
instagram because i am going to make a
much better version of this i'm going to
spend some time and actually do an
entire video in clips so you want to
check that out follow me there and i'll
be posting that later wow i just looked
down and i
thought that i was emoji but it's
actually my real face
so that's i don't know if that's good
here's my full video hey guys i wanted
to show you some of the test videos and
photos that i shot on the brand new
iphone 12.
[Music]
thanks for watching my little mini video
here that i made on clips i hope you
enjoyed it i had so much fun making it
look for more soon
bye
ah so fun i love this also exports it
out as hdr which is really cool so when
you go into photos you have the option
to choose photos
or posters so they have these little
like text blocks
that you can edit and work off of so
they've got
just the regular text some photos
occasions vintage oh i like that game
over one
cinematic okay there's actually a lot
more than i remember from the previous
version
i'm gonna pick this one youtube
dot uh can't type now we're gonna have
that at the end
oh there's like a little animation and
everything
super official this is so easy it's
shocking i'm gonna shoot a feature
filming clips
maybe quibby will have some leftover
money quibby was gone before i ever
learned what it was
i'm impressed i mean look how easy this
is to edit you can drag and drop
clips move them around it's so easy that
i just i'm reconsidering all the hours
and time
that i spend making these videos and
final cut videos now let's get out the
ipad and see what else we can do
i have sent my project over to my ipad i
can just open it up right here in the
little file browser
and there it is you'll notice if you've
used the clips app previously
that now it is in a different aspect
ratio and also it is in a horizontal
format so you can see the interface is
now
easily accessible if you want to hit
record with your thumb since this is
kind of how you would be holding the
ipad
so everything is over here easily
accessible flip the camera
and flip it back so what i really wanted
to show you
was this so i'm going to go into one of
these little areas here since this is in
a vertical format
so i decided that i wanted to change my
day with iphone 12 to
something else scribble to delete now
i'm going to say
just dean's
best day
ever
it just it did it did it i wrote it it
wrote it
for me and i i know
cool so it's moving around you can see
it's these little cursors are kind of
popping up around my head
that's so that you can add it to do
tracking i'll just click on it
enable tracking and then i can put this
wherever i want and it'll kind of just
sort of stick to my face like here we go
look at that
justine's best day ever i really like
that they updated the ipad app so that
you can now use
the apple pencil it's basically just
like the iphone version just on a bigger
screen
you can change the aspect ratio here's
all of your effects that you can add
to all of the various clips yeah look at
this i'm adding all these cool effects
i love this thank you guys so much for
watching i am so excited about this
updated clips app it's going to make it
so much easier to create simple content
for social media i'd love to hear what
you guys think about it leave them in
the comments below and i will see you in
my next video